bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre cet
après-midi en séance
l'examen d'une proposition de loi ump
sur la simplification des normes
applicables aux collectivités
territoriales le texte a entamé son
parcours sénatoriales en octobre dernier
un an et demi après la remise d'un
rapport d'eric doligé à nicolas sarkozy
ce parcours a été stoppée net
alors la majorité sénatoriale a en effet
déposé une multitude d'amendements sur
ce texte qui était inscrit dans une
niche parlementaire empêchant ainsi son
vote pour lutter contre les 400000
normes en vigueur actuellement
la proposition de loi doligé propose
d'instituer un principe de
proportionnalité des normes qui
autoriserait les préfets à octroyer des
dérogations en fonction de la taille des
collectivités territoriales cela
permettrait une économie de deux
milliards d'euros par an problème ce
texte se télescope avec un autre issue
des états généraux de la démocratie
territoriale un texte déposé le 12
novembre dernier et qui sera examiné en
janvier 2013 celui de jacqueline gourou
et jean pierre sueur qui visent le même
objectif la lutte contre l'inflation
normative mais propose pour y répondre
une haute autorité en charge du contrôle
et de la régulation des normes alors
tout de suite direction l'hémicycle pour
l'examen de la proposition de loi d'eric
doligé très bonne après midi à vous sur
public sénat mes chers collègues l'ordre
du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion de la proposition de loi de
simplification des normes applicables
aux collectivités locales présentée par
notre collègue monsieur eric doligé la
discussion générale a été close nous
passons donc à la discussion des
articles et avant l'article 1er à
l'amendement 16 rectifié du groupe 2
udi uc qui le présente
c'est madame voulez vous avez la parole
ma chère collègue oui monsieur le
président mesdames les ministres ce
texte est à exécution successive ce qui
ne rend pas son suivi plus simple cet
amendement est un amendement qui a été
présenté par le groupe au nom de michel
mercier notre ancien garde des sceaux et
il est extrêmement simple l'objet de cet
amendement est de poser comme principe
que ne sont applicables aux
collectivités que les normes issues de
la loi de mesures réglementaires
édictées par décret les choses ont l'air
absolument évidente d'un point de vue de
la sécurité juridique le statut de ces
normes et est incertain
s'agit-il de directives administratif ou
d'actes administratifs au sens strict du
terme
cette incertitude est à l'origine de
très nombreux contentieux devant les
tribunaux administratifs
aussi nous proposons simplement de
fermer le robinet normatif en consacrant
un principe de saine administration en
posant dès le départ de ce texte que ne
sont applicables aux collectivités
territoriales que les normes issues de
loi ou de mesures réglementaires
édictées par décret merci ma chère
collègue avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président avant de
donner l'avis de la commission je
voudrais d'abord excusé auprès de nos
collègues jacqueline gourault qui était
la rapporteure en titre de ce texte mais
qui est actuellement en convalescence et
donc je vais être en quelque sorte non
seulement le porte parole de la
commission mais également son porte
parole puisque la commission a examiné
l'ensemble des amendements que nous
allons examiner sous sous ce nom pas sa
présidence le président 6 heures mais
avec la participation de jacqueline
gourault donc sur l'amendement de
monsieur mercier du groupe
centriste la commission demande le
retrait sinon un avis défavorable
pourquoi pourquoi parce que il est
séduisant
c'est cet amendement sans aucun doute
sauf que il écarte sans plus d'examens
par exemple l'application de règles
découlant de règlements fédéraux alors
même que le pouvoir réglementaire lors a
été officiellement délégué s'agissant
par exemple d'équipements sportifs il
passe sous silence également le problème
des textes européens qui peuvent imposer
des normes aux collectivités
territoriales et puis c'est un certain
nombre de normes sont heureusement
facultative telles que les normes afnor
tant qu'elles n'ont pas été étendue par
voie de décret le sel qui concerne les
équipements sportifs qui résulte des
directives des fédérations
internationales s'impose souvent de fait
aux collectivités donc un rendement en
apparence séduisant sans aucun doute
mais qui pose de gros problèmes et qui
laisse de côté un certain nombre de voix
normative qui s'imposent aujourd'hui aux
collectivités locales doc la commission
demande le retrait sinon ce sera un avis
défavorable
merci à vis du gouvernement madame la
ministre merci monsieur le président
c'est lé président monsieur le
rapporteur
je me permets juste un rappel un plus
générale avant l'article 1er 2 parce que
nous avons reçus très tardivement
l'avis du conseil d'état et que je
souhaite avec ma collègue anne marie
escoffier que les choses soient dites en
amont la discussion que nous avons eue
sur les six amendements ce que nous
allons avoir pendant sur les amendements
portent sur la question de l'adaptation
des normes aux particularités locales
sur ce point donc le gouvernement avait
demandé un avis au conseil d'état dont
afin de l'éclairer sur les dispositions
à prendre
et cet avis a été rendu tard il conclut
à ce que notre droit contient toutes les
dispositions permettant aux législateurs
d'adapter contrairement à ce qu'on avait
pu dire à un moment donné
d'adapter les normes applicables aux
particularités locales sous réserve que
ces adaptations respecte des principes
constitutionnels d'égalité de nos
tutelles
dans son avis donc rendue fin novembre
mi-novembre soit quelques jours après
que nous soyons réunis la première fois
le conseil d'état expliqué je le cite
pour que ce soit porté à votre compte
rendu l'attribution d'un pouvoir
réglementaire aux collectivités par la
loi n'est pas par elle-même contraire au
principe d'égalité
l'attribution par la loi de pouvoir de
dérogation à la norme nationale ou de
pouvoir d'adaptation de la norme
nationale respecte même le principe
d'égalité si elle remplit deux
conditions la modulation de la norme
repose sur une différence objective
d'une part et la différence de
traitement qui en découle est en rapport
direct avec le but visé par le texte de
loi une loi peut donc prévoir dans
chaque cas les circonstances qui
autoriserait les collectivités à déroger
à la mise en oeuvre de telles ou telles
dispositions
il revient aussi au législateur de se
saisir de cette question
en mesurant à chaque fois au cas
d'espèce
si les conditions essentielles de mise
en oeuvre des libertés publiques ne
dépendent pas uniquement des
collectivités ce qui compte qu'ils
reviendraient à la jurisprudence
constitutionnelle
chaque loi doit prévoir l'articulation
entre le pouvoir réglementaire du
premier ministre tient de l'article 37
de la constitution et le pouvoir
réglementaire des collectivités il faut
le rappeler la loi peut aussi prévoir
qu'un décret en conseil d'état précise
les modalités de mise en oeuvre d'une
norme générale selon la situation
objective rencontré législateur peut
parfaitement invité le gouvernement à
prévoir les modalités concrètes de
l'adaptation des normes qu'ils votent à
la particularité des territoires qui les
ciblent devoir être soumis à son
attention particulière
j'attire en revanche votre attention sur
la conclusion du conseil d'état que je
n'étais pas en mesure de vous donner
lors de notre dernier débat et qui dit
ceci notre droit permet déjà de faire
plus et mieux que ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui dégager une règle générale
l'adaptation des normes au niveau local
serait vain et surtout la rédaction
d'une telle règle générale la rendrait
peu intelligible suscitant une forte
insécurité juridique nous prendrions
donc le risque de complexifier le droit
applicable aux collectivités alors qu'il
suffit de faire des lois plus clair plus
opérantes mieux adapté aux réalités des
territoires
c'est précisément ce que nous cherchons
à faire dans le texte de modernisation
de l'action publique yle
décentralisation sur lequel nous
travaillons actuellement
vous m'aviez demandé cette précision
avec l'admr et à quoi est-ce que fier
nous avons tenu à pouvoir vous la faire
tenir officiellement et en séance c'est
désormais chose faite maintenant il me
revient
la position du gouvernement avec mes
excuses monsieur le président donc
l'amendement vise sans doute dans un
sourcil je vois plus son auteur dans un
souci de clarté à identifier précisément
les normes opposable aux collectivités
territoriales il présente des faiblesses
juridiques
ça a déjà été dit d'ailleurs par le
rapporteur et dans sa rédaction actuelle
on peut s'interroger sur la portée de la
disposition plusieurs interprétations
serait possible première interprétation
l'interprétation stricte qui conduit à
en conclure que seuls les normes visé
dans l'article additionnel sont
applicables aux collectivités
territoriales c'est à dire les lois ou
les décrets ceci exclut les arrêtés qui
ne seraient plus applicables aux
collectivités mais aussi les règles d'un
rang supérieur à la loi dans la
hiérarchie des normes
c'est à dire les règlements européens
voire même la constitution ce qui n'est
pas envisageable
vous en conviendrez largement avec moi
dans l'ordre juridique national les
collectivités territoriales ne saurait
se soustraire aux normes de valeur
constitutionnelle d'application directe
par exemple celles issues de la charte
de l'environnement
pour toutes ces raisons la première
interprétation ne serait pas la bonne et
sans doute encore venez vous vous même
la deuxième interprétation est plus
souple
elle permettrait de considérer que seuls
les arrêtés ne sont pas applicables aux
collectivités en la nature des actes
réglementaires n'est pas conditionnée
par les catégories de publics concernés
et parle des considérations tenant à la
répartition des compétences au sein de
l'exécutif et aux conditions d'exercice
alimentaire donc en l'absence de
précisions apportées par l'auteur de cet
amendement on regarde son objet et de sa
portée le gouvernement ne peut qu être
hostiles au principe de soustraire les
collectivités l'application de tout
autre acte juridique que les lois et les
décrets
je pense que vous allez allègrement le
retirer merci madame la ministre madame
boulet allègrement je ne sais pas mais
j'ai déjà le retirer maire ministre
l'amendement est retirée madame boulet
alors il est retiré nous en arrivons
avant l'article 1er à l'amendement 24
basse et vous madame boulet qu'il
défendait
je crois qu'il va être retiré aussi
parce que compte tenu de l'avis du
conseil d'état que vient nuire madame le
ministre je pense que son retrait
s'impose merci l'amendement est retiré
nous en arrivons donc à l'article 1er et
je suis saisi de deux amendements
discussion commune l'amendement numéro 2
de monsieur doligé ont une âme les
ministes merci mesdames les ministres
des présentes à 2 sur ce texte qui me
paraît un peu important et merci de nous
avoir rappelé la vie que vous avez reçu
peut-être tardivement mais qui est quand
même et éclairant et je pense que déjà
rien que l'intérêt de ce texte si j'ose
dire c'est de pouvoir avoir fait dire un
peu le droit ou au moins la règle de
manière à ce que l'on puisse à chaque
fois que l'on fait une loi ou que le
gouvernement aucun parlementaire fait
une proposition de bien réfléchir à la
manière de rédiger cette loi dans sa
clarté dans ses applications voir dans
son adaptabilité puisque la limite
chaque loi peut-être adaptable en
fonction d'un certain nombre de critères
alors bon je présente bien sûr mon
amendement et madame goulet un
amendement complémentaires
compte tenu de ce que j'ai entendu on
risque d'avoir un peu le même le même
débat donc l'objectif était puisque
l'article premier était supprimée de
rétablir un article beaucoup plus simple
et beaucoup plus court qui avait pour
but et c'était le souhait de notre
amendement d'introduire parmi les
principes généraux de la
décentralisation fixées par le code
général des collectivités territoriales
qui détermine notamment les normes
opposable aux collectivités un principe
général d'adaptation selon des critères
objectifs des prescriptions et
procédures techniques législatives et
réglementaires applicables aux
collectivités territoriales merci mon
cher collègue sous-amendement numéro 25
padam goulet l'amendement de ces deux
liger prévoit donc à l'alinéa 3 les mots
peuvent prévoir et que je prévoyais mois
de remplacer par prévoir mais je crois
que le cet amendement va subir le même
sort que l'amendement précédent donc on
va attendre l'avis de la commission
merci avait de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur je crois que madame goulée
monsieur doligé ont bien pressentie
quelle serait la vie delà de la
commission contenu en plus de ceux de ce
l'avis du conseil d'état que nous a
présenté et madame la ministre
l'avis défavorable où la demande de
retrait de la commission se trouve je
dirais conforter merci yahvé du
gouvernement madame la ministre
oui mais ma vie monsieur le président
compte tenu de ce que je viens de lire
même si on comprend la jeunesse de
l'amendement sa volonté et au fond on
pourrait à partager mais je pense que
endroit on ne peut pas improviser l'avis
du conseil d'état s'imposer je ne peux à
peine que je vous redonne
les motifs ou les avez entendus à
l'instant merci monsieur doligé madame
boulet pour revenir à l'avis du conseil
d'état je rappelle qu'il avait donné un
avis déjà l'eau qu'ils avaient beaucoup
travaillé sur le sujet il avait dû
rendre un avis déjà début octobre au
président du sénat donc il a dû
retravailler sur son avis et leur
préciser il serait presque intéressant
de mettre à la place de l'article 1er
l'avis du conseil d'état qui permettrait
effectivement article premier avis du
conseil d'état sur le sujet et enfin moi
ça me parait paraît important de le
rappeler mais bien évidemment je vais
retirer l'amendement puisque il ya
globalement il est satisfait par l'avis
du conseil d'état
merci il en va de même pour le
sous-amendement madame boulet ils sont
retirés nous en arrivons à l'amendement
12 rectifié terre qui le défend souvent
goulet je les en primeur collège crois
qu'il est je crois qu'il les retirait
monsieur le président pour les raisons
évoquées précédemment
merci il est retiré nous en arrivons
donc à l'article 1er avec une demande de
parole de monsieur michel
je vous en prie mon cher collègue la
déclaration du gouvernement et la
lecture de l'arrêt du conseil d'état je
voudrais dire deux mots d'abord dire que
nous ne sommes pas hostiles à tout à la
kabylité des normes
sauf que maintenant il ya une décision
du conseil d'état qui est très claire et
qu'à mon avis le coiffeur et d'ailleurs
aux états généraux a parlé de cette
question et que tout ce qui doit être
revue dans le cadre global des lois de
décentralisation pour voir ce qui sera
possible de faire est également je dirai
tout à l'heure un peu plus longuement le
à l'affût des états généraux le
président bayle a demandé à jean pierre
sueur à madame gouro de réfléchir à la
question une proposition de loi a été
déposée elle sera examinée fin janvier
son rapporteur a été désigné c'est notre
collègue alain richard et avec ce que
nouveau pardon
il va être désigné demain la semaine
prochaine ce sera vraisemblablement
notre collègue alain richard grant mais
xavier cette question au conseil d'état
on peut le dire et donc avec le vote
nous émettrons tout à l'heure et qui
pour notre part sera positif si les
choses se déroulent normalement on aura
déjà un certain nombre d'articles qui
permettront d'avancer et ensuite à la
fin du mois de janvier
nous verrons également un certain nombre
d'autres articles arriver et puis madame
la ministre
peut-être que moment vous présenterez
votre loi sur la l'article 3
décentralisation il aura également un
certain nombre d'autres dispositions
dont tout ceci nous satisfait et devrait
satisfaire les nombreux élus locaux qui
réclament
je dirais plus ou moins de plus de
souplesse dans l'application des normes
par les conseils municipaux
merci mon cher collègue monsieur n'à
richert permettent d'ajouter un bref
commentaire à les changes qui vient
d'avoir lieu
pour peut-être préciser un tout petit
peu le mode d'emploi d'un avis du
conseil d'état
comme son nom l'indiqué ce n'est pas une
décision d'un avis qu'il rend
gouvernement sur sa demande laquelle
normalement doit préciser qu'elles sont
juste les questions sur lesquelles il
convient de répondre pour pour répondre
à l'idée d'eric doligé qui est dire
pourquoi ne pas en faire un article
je crois que la raison de ne pas le
faire c'est simplement que la vocation
même d'un avis du conseil est de faire
le résumé du droit qui existe déjà dire
qu'il n'apporte rien au droit en vigueur
simplement il explicité il en fait la
synthèse donc je remercie beaucoup
madame la ministre lebranchu de nous en
avoir donné lecture ce qui veut dire que
nous pourrons disposer de ce texte et de
le lire de façon plus réfléchie dans le
travail qui va se poursuivre sur cette
question des normes devraient indiquer
également que président du sénat a bien
voulu répondre au président sueur qui
raidement de quelques-uns d'entre nous
l'avait questionné sur l' usage des avis
du conseil d'état rendu sur des
propositions de loi et le premier cas a
été précisément la proposition de loi de
notre collègue eric doligé cette réponse
du président là que je ne commande pas
et de dire cet avis et la propriété en
quelque sorte intellectuelle du puisque
là le principe c'est que les avis du
conseil d'état ne sont pas publiques
avec des exceptions avec l'accord du
gouvernement
le l'avis du conseil d'état sur une
proposition de loi restera à la
disposition de l'auteur de la
proposition de loi c'est une réponse que
je respecte parfaitement qui va tout de
même demandé un petit effort
d'interprétation parce que quand il ya
plusieurs auteurs d'une proposition de
loi
il devra l'eau qui se partagent la
décision à prendre sur sa diffusion mais
vrai souligné que le gouvernement est
collégiale et donc lorsqu'un avis sur un
projet de loi est rendue par conseil
d'état au gouvernement tous les
ministres disposent
lorsqu'une proposition de loi entre en
discussion
si à la suite de l'avis du conseil qui
en principe ne serait pas une bonne
nouvelle
l'auteur décide de ne pas donner suite à
sa proposition ce qui veut dire que la
vie a été
ils ont lancé il est tout à fait
loisible à l'auteur de la proposition de
loi initiale de ne pas donner suite et
donc de ne pas le faire circuler en
revanche une fois que la proposition de
loi est mise en débat il me semble que
la collégialité et celle de l'ensemble
de l'assemblée et donc
il me semble à recommander que sauf des
raisons impérieuses
l'auteur de la proposition de loi fasse
connaître un ensemble de ses collègues
et en particulier à ses collègues de
commissions et aux rapporteurs ce qu'est
l'ensemble de l'avis du conseil d'état
sur une proposition doit ce qui permet
de profiter ensemble des clarifications
qu'il comporte et éventuellement des
conseils qu'il contient
merci mon cher collègue l'article 1er
dans quel supprimé nous en arrivons à
l'article 2 avec deux demandes de prise
de parole monsieur detraigne alors
monsieur favier pour le groupe crc osait
la parole monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues je veux
dire que notre débat parlementaire sur
cette ppl est me semble-t-il la plus
surréaliste
c'est en effet la troisième fois que ce
texte vient en séance et on voit bien
une suscite toujours pas un grand
enthousiasme ni de la part de la
commission qu'il a pourtant adopté ni
contre où contre toute attente le texte
qui vient à nouveau devant nous ni par
l'auteur lui-même du texte qui a
maintenant je crois un peu de mal à
reconnaître son projet malgré de
nombreuses heures de débats nous sommes
restés sur les thématiques on sait très
générales sans examiner réellement le
contenu qui relève à notre avis de
diverses mesures disparates sans
cohérence entre elles et bien souvent
éloignés de l'objet du texte qui le plus
souvent change les normes mais ne les
diminuent pas
le coeur de ce texte est en fait le
contenu de son article premier qui a été
fort heureusement donc supprimée par la
commission et dont nous venons donc de
débattre de ces réécritures à partir de
divers amendements qui touche tente de
mettre en oeuvre un principe de
proportionnalité des normes et je me
félicite évidemment que cet article soit
maintenant complètement supprimée car
pour notre part nous récusons
effectivement cette notion de
proportionnalité des normes pour nous il
y a effectivement un principe
républicain d'égalité des citoyens
devant la loi et on n'est pas évidemment
pour une loi à géométrie variable avec
l'article 2 donc et les débats qui vont
suivre sur les amendements rattaché à
cet article les additionnels qui
concerne aussi cette nouvelle commission
consultative d'évaluation des normes
nous allons donc ouvrir un débat qui
devrait au moins se poursuivre dans le
cadre du futur projet de loi de
décentralisation et de réforme de
l'action publique dont on sait qu'un
avant-projet circulent je ne sais pas
quelle est évidemment la qualité de ceux
de ce projet de cet avant projet et qui
traite évidemment aussi de cet article 2
et qui diffère évidemment donc de celui
que vient également de déposer sous
forme de proposition de loi notre
président de commission jean-pierre
sueur et notre collègue jacqueline
gourault c'est dire combien donc les
positions sont encore mouvante et on est
pour le moins confuse
l'avenir de cette proposition est pour
le moins fragile donc et celui du texte
même de cet article 2 est promis à des
modifications importantes avant même
qu'il ne s'applique
nous sommes donc dans l'expectative et
pensons que c'est une autre motion de
renvoi était donc bien la bonne solution
car cela aurait permis en fait
d'associer l'ensemble des réflexions sur
ce sujet à une réforme globale de
l'action publique
aussi nous n'allons pas nous associer à
une sorte de course de vitesse pour
essayer de déterminer le premier qui
aura fait voter un texte sur les normes
le sujet à mon avis est trop important
pour nous livrer un tel exercice et les
préoccupations des élus locaux trop
sérieuse pour être traitée ainsi dès son
premier passage en séance une majorité
d'entre nous pensaient que les sujets
les contenus de cette ppl était bien
trop vaste pour trouver une issue dans
un débat de niche parlementaire
cela reste devrait encore aujourd'hui il
ne s'agit pas de simples mesures de
réduction des normes comme le titre
pourrait le laisser entendre
mais d'un ensemble de propositions
content de nouvelles normes parfois
semblant plus relevé du règlement que de
la loi et intervenants dans de multiples
domaines de compétences qui semble pour
certaines être appelée à être modifiée
prochainement et donc d'ailleurs pour
notre part avant de s'attaquer à ce
sujet des normes comment sont peut-être
déjà par clarifier les compétences des
collectivités
enfin vous le savez il est des
propositions contenues dans cette loi en
particulier celles concernant les ccas
que nous ne saurions de toute façon
accepté nous sommes déjà exprimée lors
des débats précédents sur ce sujet aussi
donc pour toutes ces raisons nous nous
abstiendrons sur de nombreux articles et
nous voterons contre sur d'autres ayant
déposé sur ce texte une motion de renvoi
chacun comprendra aussi donc que nous
nous serions adopter cette proposition
l'état voté contre ce texte proposition
de loi sans peut-être évidemment le vote
qui correspond le mieux à notre
appréciation globale sur ce texte en
l'état actuel évidemment de son écriture
la disparition de certains articles
peut-être comme l'article 18 concernant
les crs pourrait peut-être faire évoluer
notre vote vers une abstention qui
pourrait qualifiée de constructive
nous sommes donc très attentif aux
débats qui vont suivre car collègue
monsieur michel merci monsieur le
président comme je les ai évoqué tout à
l'heure de ma première intervention dans
la proposition de loi qu'un compte
déposer nos cadets poser nos collègues
jean pierre sueur et jacqueline gourault
on revoit totalement le statut de la
commission nationale d'évaluation des
normes on propose rend pas si cette
commission par une autorité indépendante
dont l'autorité lors d'activités
seraient plus incontestable et que
répond mission de contrôler l'ensemble
des normes applicables ou susceptibles
d'être appliquées aux collectivités
territoriales et leurs établissements
publics
dans ces conditions nous pensons qu'il
est sage aujourd'hui contrairement à ce
que nous avions fait en commission des
lois mais en commission nous n'en avions
pas encore le texte de la proposition de
loi sueur gouro de pensions qu'il est
sage aujourd'hui de ne pas
gardez l'article 2 et les artic
additionnel après l'article 2 et de
renvoyer cette question à la proposition
de loi ont reçu heures c'est la raison
pour laquelle en ce qui nous concerne
nous retirons nos amendements 36 35 37
39 40 41 et 42
nous voterons s'ils sont maintenues
contre l'article 2 et les article
additionnel après l'article 2 qui
concerne la commission nationale
d'évaluation des normes et ce faisant
nous nous retrouverons sur un texte
consensuel après les travaux en
commissions déjà pris nos bourreaux et
ce texte consensuel nous le voterons en
fin de discussion afin que les
propositions qui ont été faites par
notre collègue eric doligé et qui ont
été amendés quelquefois par la
commission pas aidé par madame gouro
puisse être d'ores et déjà transmises
éventuellement à l'assemblée nationale
et pour le reste eh bien nous verrons au
moment de la discussion du d'euros
passant de loi guru sueur ce qui aura
lieu de faire en plus pour répondre aux
désirs des collectivités territoriales
merci monsieur michel nous en arrivons
donc à la discussion des amendements
l'amendement 36 s'est retirée si j'ai
bien compris monsieur michel un
amendement 68 de madame gourou au nom de
la commission des lois qu'ils défense
c'est monsieur détraigne oui c'est un
simple amendement pour corriger une
erreur de référence merci à vis du
gouvernement
merci je mets dans kowal amendement 68
qui elles sont ce qu'ils sont pour son
adoption
avis contraire
il est adopté un amendement 35 il est
retiré un monsieur michel amendement 37
également nous en arrivons donc à deux
amendements discussion commune le 39 et
38 ils sont maintenus retirer retirer
parfait je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'article 2 est ce qu'il ya des demandes
de prise de parole monsieur doligé oui
monsieur le président j'ai écouté avec
attention bien sûr monsieur michel et
puis j'avais pris connaissance avec
intérêt de la proposition de loi de jean
pierre sueur et de notre de notre
collègue jacqueline gourault à qui je
souhaite d'ailleurs un prompt
rétablissement bien sûr puisque nous
aurions tous aimé je dis pas ça pour
monsieur des treilles mais nous aurions
tous aimé qu'elle soit assise à sa place
pour pouvoir suivre ce ce texte alors
j'ai écouté avec beaucoup d'attention ce
qui a été dit par monsieur favier puis
par monsieur michel monsieur favier
contrairement à ce que vous dites je
reconnais tout à fait mon texte vous
avez dit vous ne reconnaissez pas votre
texte etc
mais c'est quand même passé un certain
nombre de mois depuis que ce texte a été
présenté a été proposé a été discutée a
été vu et revu en commission nous avons
eu des échanges nombreux avec le
rapporteur et avec le président de la
commission entre autres le conseil
d'état se prononcer sur le sujet
également je vais rappeler à mon
collègue tout à l'heure qui m'a parlé du
conseil d'état qu'effectivement c'était
le président du sénat ancien qu'il avait
demandé il a dû être demandée par le
nouveau président du sénat qui l'a reçu
et c'est donc le président du sénat qui
avait demandé et qui a été le
destinataire et qui était propriétaire
de du texte et donc c'était à lui de
faire le choix de ce qu'il souhaitait
faire vis-à-vis de notre assemblée pour
ma part je suis tout à fait ouvert à
toute connaissance de ce texte par
l'ensemble des collègues bien sûr parce
qu'il me paraît que c'est plus
intéressant d'avoir l'avis du conseil
d'état pour pouvoir travailler que de ne
pas la voir
ceci étant je pense que tout l'intérêt
du texte aussi ça a été quand même de
faire prendre conscience ou de
rassembler dans un texte un certain
nombre de réflexions que nous entendons
tous sur le terrain sur la direction et
moi du terme le ras le bol des normes en
gros sur le plan territorial ce qui veut
pas dire qu'ils qu'on n'a pas besoin de
normes on a besoin on a besoin aussi
d'être un peu raisonnable aussi bien
dans les collectivités que au parlement
lorsque l'on est dicté un certain nombre
de normes alors le texte est largement
modifié on a bien vu l'article 20 bon
avec ce qui a été dit par le conseil
d'état moi je trouve que c'est une
avancée quand même très sérieuse alors
en ce qui concerne le texte qui a été
proposée par jean pierre sueur et pas
jacqueline go il est vrai qu'il remet en
cause complètement l'article 2 oui non
mais remet en cause complètement
l'article 2 c'est évident moi je les lui
en détails et je me suis intéressé au
texte qui a été réalisé par nos deux
collègues on saint-ex intéressant il
essaye de refondre à l'intérieur d'une
structure un certain nombre de
structures qui pourraient avoir qui
existent voire qui pourraient avoir des
pouvoirs étendus et en l'occurrence en
matière de normes peut-être avec
quelques limites parce que je crois
qu'il ya des avis conformes ou des
choses comme ça qu'ils vont te poser
quelques difficultés montfa bref ceci
étant si l'on considère et je pense que
le rôle du sénat et d'une assemblée
c'est d'essayer d'être un peu
intelligent et deux s'entendent sur un
certain nombre de sujets pas toujours
être en opposition frontale permanente
et de vouloir
j'allais dire porter comme le disait
tout à l'heure monsieur favier le
premier arrivé je pense que le but c'est
pas le premier
le but c'est de faire avancer des idées
et le président de la république a parlé
d'adaptabilité ça a été rappelé et quand
même un sujet important que
l'adaptabilité maintenance est rentré
dans l'état d'esprit de chacun d'entre
nous alors il ya eu un amendement qui a
été votée sur l'article 2 maintenant
très très sincèrement si on porte
la loi de jean-pierre sueur et de
jacqueline gourault joie plus que va
venir faire l'article 2 c'est à dire
qu'il va être détruit systématiquement
par la loi un proposition de loi ce
rigoureux donc n'aura plus aucun sens
d'avoir ce texte on va les faces et donc
moi personnellement si l'on pense
vraiment que ce texte va arriver je
pense qu'il va arriver un peu jean
pierre sueur suffisamment bien placé
pour l'inscrire donc on a quand même une
probabilité plus facile que moi de faire
inscrire mon texte
donc heureusement il ya eu des soutiens
donc je pense sincèrement que cet
article 2 et ce n'est pas dénaturer le
texte parce que moi je considérerai que
le fait de le reprendre en fin de texte
sur gouraud il fait honneur au texte il
reprend des éléments et qui était un peu
diffus dans un certain nombre d'éléments
du texte et qui sont regroupés avec une
certaine cohérence et cohésion
bon donc moi je serais d'avis de retirer
l'article 2 est ce qui donnerait plus de
cohérence avec le texte qui va venir
alors je sais pas comment ça peut se
formaliser je crois que ça a été demandé
par monsieur michel non un amendement de
suppression est ce qu'on peut faire un
amendement de suppression sur le
président la commission peut tout à fait
le faire alors laeken monsieur le
président alors monsieur le président de
la commission et monsieur michel merci
monsieur doligé mes chers collègues
mesdames les ministres monsieur le
président je voulais reprendre quelques
propos qui ont été tenus à l'instant par
notre collègue eric doligé eux il est
clair que dans cette affaire de normes
qui a donné lieu à beaucoup de débats ce
que nous souhaiterions faire c'est
d'ajouter les apports pour arriver à
quelque chose qui
contribuer à faciliter la tâche de nos
collègues élus dans les différentes
communes de ce pays
par conséquent vous avez bien vu que
lorsque à l'initiative du président jean
pierre bel madame la présidente de la
délégation aux collectivités locales et
moi même avons été chargée de proposer
un texte sur le statut de l'élu
un texte sur les nomme textes sur
lesquels nous désignerons le 19 décembre
deux rapporteurs eh bien nous avons eu
le souci s'agissant des normes de
prendre en compte l'ensemble du travail
proposé par eric doligé et de nous
concentrer sur un seul point
un seul qui est de donner plus de
pouvoirs à la commission consultative en
la transformant en une haute autorité
ayant davantage de prérogatives
par conséquent s'il pouvait y avoir un
accord entre nous pour adopter un
amendement de suppression que pourrait
proposer notre rapporteur yves detraigne
s'il le veut bien
de l'article nous pourrions il peut le
faire je sais qu'il peut le faire que le
règlement le permet nous pourrions
l'adopter ensemble comme l'a suggéré
eric doligé dans un sens positif
ce serait pour ajouter ce qui sera le
fruit de la future loi préparée avec
jacqueline gourault à l'apport qui sera
celui de tous les autres articles sans
exception de lalo de la proposition de
loi d'eric doligé bien entendu amender
avec l'apport des différents membres de
la commission des lois qui ont présenté
des amendements
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
après jean pierre sueur remercier notre
collègue eric doligé comme il l'a dit ce
que nous voulons ici c'est trouver des
accords communs pour arriver à un texte
final après deux propositions de loi
peut-être après d'ailleurs le projet de
loi du gouvernement qui règle cette
question des normes applicables aux
collectivités territoriales donc notre
collègue eric doligé a le premier je
dirais déposé une proposition de loi
puisqu'elle avait été chargé d'une
mission à l'époque par le président de
la république s'est trouvé ça doit bien
aujourd'hui finalement en séance mais
entre temps il s'est passé quelque chose
de nouveau et je le remercie de bien
vouloir renoncer à l'article 2 d'or dans
ces conditions si notre rapporteur de la
commission des lois proposé un
amendement de suppression nous le
voterons est ce que nous souhaitons
c'est au bout de 18 ans d'après midi
arrivé à un vote positif sur les
articles en discussion de la ppn doligé
merci monsieur michel monsieur de près
n'y mais compte tenu des positions
convergentes et de l'auteur de la
proposition de loi eric doligé et de
jean-pierre michel pour le le groupe
socialiste
j'ai déposé un amendement de suppression
de l'article 2 je compte aussi qu'avec
cette suppression de l'article 2 qui
posait quelques difficultés eh bien nous
arrivions comme le souhaite l'auteur de
la proposition de loi
au terme de l'examen du texte avant les
quatre heures réservées à cette niche
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement 76,1 de la commission qui
vise donc à supprimer l'article 2 qui
pourrait être rédigé un article de
supprimer cet article
est-ce que vous en êtes d'accord mes
chers collègues je le mets aux voix
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis contraire je n'en vois pas
donc l'article 2 est supprimé après
l'article de nous arrivons à
l'amendement
rente de monsieur michel il est supprimé
alors toujours après l'article de
l'amendement 41
il est supprimé après l'article de
l'amendement 42 il est retiré
nous en arrivons donc à l'article 2 bis
avec l'amendement 69 de la commission
monsieur detraigne oui c'est simplement
une rectification d'erreurs de référence
à vis de la commission d'avis du
gouvernement favorable
je le mets au mois quels sont ceux qui
sont pour l'adoption d'amendements 69
il est pas d'avis contraire il est
adopté je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'article 2 bis
quels sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
de l'article 2 bis avis contraire je
n'en vois pas il est adopté l'article 3
est supprimé l'article iv également nous
en arrivons à l'article 4 bis avec
l'amendement 70 de la commission
monsieur detraigne c'est également un
amendement de rectification d'erreur
matérielle
merci avis favorable du gouvernement
madame la ministre merci je vais donc
mettre aux voix cet amendement 70 quels
sont ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire il est adopté je mets aux
voix l'article 4 bis quels sont ceux qui
souhaitent adopter l'article 4 bis avis
contraire il est adopté
article 5 même vote même vote
nous en arrivons à l'article 6 avec la
demande mans 72 de la commission
monsieur detraigne
oui la certification le conditionne sur
ce texte sur cet article 6 je voudrais
rappeler que la certification ne
conditionne pas l'entrée en vigueur d'un
acte qui est subordonné son entre en
vigueur à sa publicité et à sa
transmission représentant de l'état donc
il ya aucun texte qui exige cette
certification donc c'est une disposition
en conséquence superflu donc avis
défavorable merci sur l'amendement 72 il
est présenté par la commission et c'est
un avis défavorable
non d'abord il faut approuver la loi il
faut approuver j'ai dit défavorable
il faut approuver l'amendement 512 c'est
ce que je vous proposerais bien je vais
mal compris ma femme le ministre on
n'avait pas tout à fait compris le sens
de l'observation qui était fait
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur oui en l'état actuel du droit
l'exécutif certifie effectivement sous
sa responsabilité le caractère
exécutoire déjà des actes la proposition
de loi tout en conservant le caractère
impératif de la certification en des
limites précisément le chant dans les
cas prévus par la loi et dans la mesure
où les recherches effectuées n'ont pas
permis de détecter le texte qui prévoit
une obligation de certification pour une
ou plusieurs catégories d'actes et où la
mise en oeuvre systématique de cette
certification paraît difficile à
réaliser
il semble préférable de revenir à la
rédaction initiale 2 du code général des
collectivités territoriales
donc dans ces conditions là le
gouvernement donne un avis de sagesse
voir favorable merci madame la ministre
je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement 72 quels sont ceux qui sont
pour l'adoption de cet amendement
ali contraire je n'en vois pas il est
adopté et je mets l'eau ou à l'article 6
ils sont ce qu'ils sont pour l'adoption
avis contraire il est adopté
après l'article 6 un amendement 50 de
monsieur michel
cet amendement est un amendement
principalement de monsieur mazuir qui
est absent et donc je vais me permettre
de l'argumenter afin que madame la
ministre puisse répondre aux
interrogations de monsieur mazuir en
effet notre volet qui souhaite attirer
l'attention du gouvernement sur la
situation des agents des catégories ses
titulaires de la fonction publique
territoriale lauréats de l'examen
professionnel de rédacteur
les conditions générales d'accès à la
fonction publique qui sont communes aux
trois fonctions publiques s'applique aux
fonctionnaires aux agents non titulaires
le recrutement d'agents au sein des
collectivités territoriales répondre est
guetté par la loi du 26 janvier 84 par
principe recrutement de ces
fonctionnaires s'effectue par concours
toutefois un recrutement sans concours
est possible dans un diplôme de cas
énumérés par la loi une fois en poste
est titulaire ces agents peuvent
prétendre un changement de cadre
d'emplois par la voie de la promotion
interne soit on regarde nos acquis
professionnels soit après réussite à un
examen professionnel
l'intervention de monsieur masure porte
précisément sur le sort des agents de
catégorie c méritant que réussi l'examen
professionnel de rédacteur territorial
et qui règne dans la tente d'être nommé
par le collectif territoriales et leurs
établissements publics
il s'agit là d'un amendement d'appel et
monsieur mazuir serais très
reconnaissant de madame la ministre vous
avez bien lu oeuf l'informer des
possibilités d'aménagement de la règle
des quotas qui freine considérablement
la carrière des agents depuis de
catégorie c merci avis de la commission
sur le rapporteur oui bien que monsieur
michel soient pressés longtemps de
l'avis du gouvernement va quand même
passer par la vie de
de la commission il s'agit d'un
amendement qui a déjà été déposé lors de
l'examen de la loi du 12 mars 2012 sur
la précarité dans la fonction publique
et qui traite donc d'un problème
récurrent lié au nombre important de
reçus qui a dépassé largement le nombre
de postes offerts à la promotion interne
à l'examen professionnel qui avait été
ouvert par le décret du 30 décembre 2004
depuis la discussion de cette loi du 12
mars de 2012 le cadre d'emplois des
rédacteurs a été dotée d'un nouveau
statut et à l'avenir
le recrutement dans le grade de dans le
grade de rédacteur n'est plus accessible
par examen professionnel mais par la
voie de la promotion interne au choix
après avis de la commission itre hâtive
paritaire ce qui devrait progressivement
régler la question des lauréats qui ne
sont pas encore promulguée qu'il paraît
plus sage d'attendre les effets de cette
réforme plutôt que de supprimer pour
l'ensemble des cadres d'emplois de la
fonction publique territoriale
l'actuel verrou du quota donc c'est un
avis défavorable qui est émis par la
commission
merci monsieur rappaz par madame la
ministre avait du gouvernement oui un
avis aussi précis que possible puisque
c'est un sujet qui a été traitée à la
suite du groupe de travail qui a
regroupé les employeurs territoriaux et
les représentants des personnels
constitués au sein du conseil subit du
conseil supérieur pardon de la fonction
publique territoriale auquel lire
monsieur meyzieu monsieur michel font
référence fameux décret du 30 juillet
2012 portant statut particulier du cadre
d'emplois des rédacteurs territoriaux
est donc entré en vigueur le 1er août
ce décret 2012 920 étape a pris en
considération dans ses dispositions
transitoires la situation des lauréats
de l'examen professionnel exceptionnel
n'oublions pas exceptionnel d'accès au
cadre d'emplois de rédacteur territorial
donc été prévu par les décrets 2004 1547
et 2004 1548 du 30 décembre 2004 qui
n'ont pas pu être nommé dans le cadre
d'emplois des rédacteurs avant le terme
qui était fixée au 30 novembre 2011
du dispositif dérogatoire mis en oeuvre
par les décrets l'article 27 du décret
dispose que la validité de l'examen
professionnel exceptionnel est prolongée
sans limitation de durée
ainsi les lauréats conservent le
bénéfice de la réussite à l'examen et
peuvent prétendre à une promotion
interne sur ce fondement
de plus l'article 28 du décret précité a
prévu à titre temporaire bien entendu un
assouplissement significatif de la règle
du quota de promotion interne pendant
une durée de trois ans par exception aux
dispositions de l'article 9 alinéa 2 du
décret 2010 329 du 22 mars 2010 portant
dispositions statutaires communes à
divers cadres d'emplois de
fonctionnaires de la catégorie b de la
fonction publique territoriale et je dis
bien et si les normes de promu est plus
élevé que celui issu de l'application
d'un constat d'une promotion interne
pour trois recrutements externes des
promotions peuvent être prononcées dans
la limite de 5% de l'effectif du cadre
d'emplois et non un tiers 2 5% comme
c'est la règle
enfin nous avons établi une clause de
sauvegarde exceptionnel elle permet une
promotion interne en 2015 si aucune
promotion interne ne peut être prononcée
en trois ans en application des
dispositions qui précèdent les
possibilités juridiques de dôme et les
lauréats sont donc bien étendu elles
doivent permettre de répondre à la
situation de quelques 4000 lauréats de
l'examen professionnel de promotion
interne qui n'ont pu être nommées en
raison des quotas à la fin du dispositif
exceptionnel une modification de
l'article 39 de la loi 84 53 portant
dispositions statutaires relatives à la
fonction publique territoriale et donc
pas nécessaire ni utile et j'ajoute
compte tenu de ce que nous nous sommes
engagés à faire au sein du conseil
supérieur de la fonction publique
territoriale
ce serait plutôt un handicap qu'un
avantage donc il convient de souligner
qu'au plan juridique il n'est en plus
pas possible ni je pense souhaitable de
prévoir une
position légale relative au quota de
promotion interne alors que ceux ci
relèvent du pouvoir réglementaire en
vertu des dispositions de l'article 39
de la loi 84 53 du 26 janvier 84 portant
dispositions statutaires relatives à la
fonction publique territoriale
j'espère que fort de ces explications
ouverture est mise au point juridique il
est possible de retirer cet amendement
sinon voilà nous sommes bien d'accord
mi-2004 mi 2012 mi 2015 dans ce cas
c'est le moment n'était pas retiré bien
évidemment je me verrais dans
l'obligation d'y être défavorable
ministre monsieur michel que président
je me félicite d'avoir déployé cet
abonnement à lui monsieur maduin et puis
ça donne l'occasion même la ministre
d'expliquer les mesures que le
gouvernement a prises pour filles en
catégorie c est donc contenu de ces
explications je retire cet amendement et
je pense que monsieur maintenir le
retirer également meti je vais donc
mettre aux voix
l'article 7 quels sont ceux qui sont
pour l'adoption de l'article cet avis
contraire il est adopté
après l'article 7 l'amendement 17
rectifié de monsieur amoudry qu'il
présente c'est madame goulette je le
crains monsieur le président mesdames
les ministres mes chers collègues
l'article 5212 26 du code général des
collectivités locales issue de la loi du
7 décembre 2010 portant nouvelle
organisation du marché de l'électricité
autorise le versement de fonds de
concours entre syndicats visés à
l'article l 5212 24 au titre de sa
compétence d'autorité organisatrice de
la distribution d'électricité et les
communes et établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale membres de ce
syndicat afin de financer la réalisation
le fonctionnement d'un équipement public
local or certains syndicats se sont vu
interdire la possibilité de mettre en
oeuvre ces dispositions au motif que
l'article l 5212 24 ne concerne que les
syndicats intercommunaux ainsi que par
renvoi les syndicats mixtes dits fermés
en revanche les syndicats mixtes ouverts
mentionnées aux articles 5 milles
721 1 et suivants du code général des
collectivités territoriales ne serait
pas concernée même si l'article l
5722 8 précise que les dispositions de
l'article
5212 24 sont applicables parmi les
catégories toujours aussi simple les
affaires de collectivités territoriales
et d'électricité donc afin d'éviter
toute ambiguïté notre collègue à mme
aubry propose de revoir ces dispositions
afin de préciser clairement que les
dispositions prévues à l'article 5212 26
comme celles de l'article 5212 24 sont
bien applicable aux catégories de
syndicats mixtes dit ouvert merci de
votre attention
merci madame avis de la commission sur
l'amendement 17 rectifier oui merci
monsieur le président il s'agit donc
d'un amendement qui vise à permettre au
syndicat mixte ouvert le versement de
fonds de concours au titre de leur
compétence d'autorité organisatrice de
la distribution d'électricité en
direction des collectivités
territoriales qui en sont membres afin
de pouvoir financer la réalisation de
fonctionnement d'un équipement public
local force est de constater que c'est
un amendement qui n'a aucun lien avec
l'objet de notre texte donc la
commission ne permettre qu'un avis
défavorable
merci à vis du gouvernement madame la
ministre merci monsieur le président au
delà du fait que effectivement
l'amendement n'a pas de liens précis
avec le texte je voudrais faire observer
que aujourd'hui dans la dans le cadre
des travaux que nous menons pour une
prochaine loi de décentralisation
nous notre objectif est de clarifier les
compétences et d'apporter des solutions
plus opérante
s'agissant en particulier des
financements croisés et donc aujourd'hui
ce serait vraiment prématuré
d'introduire un amendement de cette
nature merci il est maintenu madame
boulet non non il est il et il est très
volontiers est allègrement retirer le
ministre coup il est retiré je vais donc
mettre aux voix l'article 8 quels sont
ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire il est adopté même vote
pour l'article 9
même votre pour l'article 10 après
l'article 10 je suis saisi de deux
amendements discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 30 de rectifier qui
le défend pour le rdmc monsieur
fortassin vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le président mesdames
les ministres mes chers collègues toute
collectivité territoriale ou tout
groupement de collectivités
territoriales maître d'ouvragé une
opération d'investissement conformément
à l'article l est c du code général des
collectivités territoriales doit assurer
20 % de participation au financement
d'une opération d'investissement
cet amendement vise à mettre en
cohérence ce nouveau dispositif avec les
règles prévues à l'article l 52 12 26 du
code général des collectivités
territoriales
concernant le financement d'un epic qui
peut m'en public local par les
collectivités mentionnées dans cet
article
ça évitera que ce soir au mans à ce que
certains et qui est l'investissement ne
soient financés à 110%
merci à vis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur oui il s'agit d'un amendement
qui propose que les fonds de concours
que peuvent percevoir une commune ou un
établissement public de coopération
intercommunale qui est maître d'ouvragé
de la part d'un syndicat auquel ils
appartiennent puissent être prises en
compte dans le calcul de la
participation minimale de 20 % qui est
imposé par le code général des
collectivités territoriales à une
collectivité maître d'ouvragé
c'est un amendement qui suscite
plusieurs observations d'abord il
dénature le principe même fixée par la
loi de participation minimale de 20 % de
la collectivité maître d ouvrage elle
même
ensuite il ne prend pas en compte la
quote-part de financement des
collectivités au budget du syndicat dont
elles reçoivent ensuite à fond de
concours d'une certaine manière la
collectivité de base finances le
syndicat qui va lui apporter un fond de
concours et enfin comme pour
l'amendement précédent la commission
constate que c'est un amendement qui n'a
aucun lien avec l'objet du texte et qui
pourrait avoir un effet pernicieux à
savoir la multiplication de syndicats
pour pouvoir attribuer des fonds de
concours sur un certain nombre
d'opérations donc la vie ne peut être
que défavorable
merci monsieur besson et je m'en excuse
j'ai oublié de vous donner la parole
pour l'art l'amendement 66 qui est
identique est ce que vous souhaitez
compléter les propos de monsieur
fortassin merci à vis du gouvernement
sur ces deux amendements madame la
ministre
oui merci monsieur président
effectivement sur sur ce point là nous
nous avons bien relever le gouvernement
a bien relevé les difficultés qui se qui
se pose est qui ont été dites en
particulier s'agissant de la réforme du
fonds d'amortissement des charges
d'électrification et on a eu on a été
très souvent saisis sur ce problème
au point qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement
travaille sur un projet de décret qui
devrait permettre de clarifier la
situation
donc dans ces conditions là le
gouvernement souhaite un retrait de cet
amendement
merci monsieur fortassin il est retiré
monsieur besson il leur était monsieur
michel goulet parole non il les deux
amendements sont retirés nous sommes
d'accord nous en arrivons après
l'article 10 à l'amendement numéro 49
qui le défend ce monsieur michel
cet amendement est d'introduire une
modification au code de la voirie
routière relatif au péage afin que ces
derniers puissent couvrir les dépenses
de toute nature liés à la construction
l'exploitation et l'entretien de
l'ouvragé d'art et des six voies d'accès
ou de dégagement merci à vis de la
commission monsieur des traînes oui je
ne vais pas rappeler le le contenu de
cet amendement qui vient d'être très
bien présentés par notre collègue michel
évidemment c'est une disposition qui n'a
pas de lien direct avec le texte et qui
mériterait me semble-t-il nous
semble-t-il une réflexion plus
approfondie que celle que nous permet
l'examen d'un amendement donc c'est un
avis défavorable
merci avait du gouvernement madame la
ministre même avis que celui qui vient
d'être dit c'est ainsi c'est un problème
très très lourd très grave qui mérite un
véritable débat est aujourd'hui je crois
que nous ne sommes pas en mesure d'y
répondre dans les circonstances
actuelles
merci monsieur michel il est retiré je
vous remercie amendement numéro 50
toujours après l'article 10
monsieur michel
je pense que le gouvernement va faire
les mêmes réponses que pour l'amendement
précédent puisqu'il s'agit de remplacer
les mots employés municipaux par les
mots agents de la fonction publique
territoriale quel que soit leur statut
ce qui d'après monsieur mazuir permet de
régler à terme de questions qui se
posent à ses employés communaux donc
j'attends la réponse du gouvernement
pour savoir quel sera le centre et
amendements merci on va d'abord demandé
l'avis de la commission
voilà alors je vais aller un petit peu
au-delà cette fois ci des explications
de monsieur michel pour dire que cet
amendement propose l'extension aux
employés communaux de la faculté de
conduire des engins agricoles ou
forestiers avec le permis de catégorie b
qui résulte de l'adoption d'un
amendement adopté par l'assemblée
nationale en nouvelle lecture de la loi
de simplification du droit et
d'allègement des démarches
administratives du 22 mars 2012
la modification proposée doit
s'apprécier en tenant compte des
principes édictés par les directives
européennes relatives au permis de
conduire qui ont été transposées dans le
code de la route
donc c'est un examen qui dépasse le
cadre du présent débat mais nous
souhaiterions avoir l'avis du
gouvernement sur cette proposition
s'ils avaient du gouvernement madame la
ministre oui merci on comprend le fait
générateur et l'explication demandé ne
va pas satisfaire l'auteur de
l'amendement en effet parce que
conformément à un article 221 4 du code
de la route les catégories de permis
exigés pour la conduite d'un tracteur
cbbc ou eux c'est sont définis en
fonction du poids total autorisé en
charge du véhicule et le cas échéant de
sa remorque vous que ce n'est pas d'une
grande simplicité mais c'est d'une
grande efficacité parce que nous ne
sommes pas du tout dans les mêmes
risques y compris vous le savez dans un
certain nombre d'incidents ou
d'accidents que vous avez vous même
noter la nouvelle directive européenne
du 20 décembre 2006 relative au permis
de conduire qui va entrer en vigueur en
vigueur pour nous le disent
janvier 2013 apporte certaines
évolutions d'abord la possibilité pour
le détenteur du permis de conduire de
catégorie b complété d'une formation
obligatoire ce que nous nous appelions
une formation complémentaire formation
donc née cette fois obligatoire de
conduire un ensemble représentant
jusqu'à 4000 250 kg de poids total
roulant autorisé d'une part et d'autre
part la création des catégories
c'est un cae qui autorise la conduite
qui autorise remparts dont la conduite
des véhicules dont le poids total en
charge est compris entre 3500 et 7500 kg
la conduite détracteurs notamment par
les agents de la fonction publique
territoriale sera donc rendue possible
pour les titulaires de ces nouveaux
permis lors délivrance sera subordonnée
au succès l'examen actuellement en cours
d'élaboration au ministère de
l'intérieur sur la base de la directive
précitée aucun assouplissement
supplémentaire du code de la route ne
pourrait être accordé en matière de
permis de conduire en l'absence de
modifications du droit communautaire en
la matière nous ne voulons pas nous
mettre en situation de porte à faux et
nous nous n'ont pas de nous rangeons à
la vie mais nous suivons cet avis parce
que en plus je rappelle que parfois la
norme protège les élus et les
fonctionnaires territoriaux et qu'il
vaut mieux être bien précis dans ce type
de cas plutôt que d'ouvrir des
contentieux qui certes ferait
jurisprudence
peut-être dans le sens souhaité mais ne
sont pas souhaitables avis défavorable
merci madame la ministre monsieur masson
monsieur monsieur le président même le
ministre chers collègues je me suis
beaucoup investi depuis presque dix ans
sur ce problème du permis de conduire
pour les employés municipaux et
territoriaux et parce que c'était
vraiment une aberration complète en ce
sens que par exemple un agriculteur qui
est le matin agriculteurs et qui est
l'après-midi employé municipal et bien
le matin il y avait le droit de conduire
son tracteur sans avoir de permis etc
il pouvait même le conduire à 16 ans et
l'après-midi le même la même personne
l'après midi quand il s'agissait de
conduire le tracteur de la petite
commune qui était exactement le même
tracteurs et qui parfois d'ailleurs été
servi aux deux et bien il ne pouvait pas
il n'avait pas le droit parce qu'il
agissait en tant qu'employé municipal
alors c'était complètement aberrant et à
de nombreuses reprises j'avais attiré
l'attention du gouvernement sur
précisément la réglementation européenne
et sur la nécessité d'avoir un
assouplissement alors l'assouplissement
il est intervenu pour les employés
municipaux alors vous ne dites madame le
ministre
disons ça poserait des problèmes avec
l'europe de mettre de remplacer le mot
employés municipaux par le mot employé à
des collectivités territoriales alors je
vous pose une question très simple
madame le ministre
quelle est exactement la directive
européenne qui autoriserait la france à
faire des assouplissements pour les
employés municipaux et qui interdirait
la france de généraliser cet
assouplissement aux employés de toutes
les collectivités territoriales moi je
me pose vraiment la question en ce sens
qu'en général quand l'europe prend des
directives
elle ne distingue pas le statut on paye
municipaux du statut employé de
collectivités territoriales parce que
d'un pays à l'autre ça peut changer
et en plus bon on a quand même des
communautés de communes des groupements
de communes m employés municipaux ça
pose quand même un problème si demain
une commune transfert la compétence à
une communauté de communes le leb havre
employé municipal qui pouvaient
auparavant conduire le tracteur ne peut
plus conduire du jour au lendemain le
tracteur je pense qu'il serait quand
même opportun que le gouvernement soit
plus claire et plus précis relais
matière
merci monsieur michel l'amendement a
maintenu maintenant est maintenue
monsieur le président merci je vais donc
mettre aux voix
cette drogue madame la mini jeux vous en
prie excusez moi mais j'ai président je
n'ai pas dû être clair mais dans
l'application de la directive le texte
qui est viendra en janvier 2013
la personne concernée devra être
titulaires des permis dont je viens de
lire notifié enfin j'ai de lire comment
dire le périmètre
mais je reviens un peu en amont lorsque
vous dites l'agriculteur le matin
conduit son tracteur l'après midi il ne
conduit pas le matin il est responsable
l'intitut personne et de ses actes
d'après midi là un employeur ce que je
disais tout à l'heure par fois la norme
protège de l'employeur c'est un premier
point et en second point tous les
personnels qui sont titulaires qui
seront titulaires de ces permis pour
reconduire des tracteurs jeu à ce moment
là votre amende pas votre demande tombe
puisque j'ai bien dit et je le redis la
conduite détracteurs notamment par des
agents de la fonction publique
territoriale ou d'autres sera rendu
possible pour les titulaires de ces
nouveaux permis
voilà donc les choses sont simples ne
s'agit pas de catégoriser les personnes
mais de les qualifier
lorsqu'elles sont titulaires d'un point
du nouveau permis de conduire
merci madame la ministre madame boulet
oui monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres ou et moi je vais évidemment
voté cet amendement
je voulais revenir sur un certain nombre
d'amendements qui ont été retirées tout
à l'heure pour cause de cavaliers le
texte initial était qu'emporter quand
même sur la simplification d'un certain
nombre de normes et s'est pas
complètement absurde que certains de nos
collègues et souhaitait déposer des
amendements qui semblait régler un
certain nombre de problèmes qui se
posaient quotidiennement collectivités
territoriales le chant c'est ensuite
réduit dans le cadre de l' exécution
successive de ce texte puisque ça fait
plusieurs fois que nous y revenons mais
il faut aussi se rappeler que quand le
texte a été déposé initialement ces
amendements qui aujourd'hui apparaissent
comme cavalier au moment où ils ont été
déposés c'est à dire et quand même
plusieurs mois avaient toute leur
légitimité
merci je vais donc mettre au voile
mandement 50 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis contraire il est adopté à
l'unanimité
je vais donc mettre aux voix l'article
quels sont ceux qui sont à accuser moi
donc il ya votre compte
je vais mettre voir l'article 11 quels
sont ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire il est adopté
et cette fois à l'unanimité article 12
avec un amendement numéro 34 ce monsieur
michel qu'il défend surpris et de
transmission des documents aux
commissions permanentes des conseils
généraux et régionaux
en fait nous proposons que le délai soit
un délai de huit jours
la commission proposait 5 je crois mais
nous pensons que c'est trop court
proposant un délai de 8 jours afin que
les élus aient le temps de voir les
documents qu'ils auront à des doutes ils
auront à délibérer
merci avait de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur la commission a fixé en
fixant dans la loi le délai de
transmission l'arrêter à cinq jours pour
tenir compte de la périodicité qui est
le plus souvent mensuel et de la teneur
des réunions de la commission permanente
donc la commission considère
considère que qu'il faut émettre un avis
défavorable sur l'amendement qui
proposait merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame la ministre je le gouvernement a
bien entendu les arguments qui ont été
développés par le sénateur michel bien
entendu aussi les arguments du
rapporteur c'est vrai que pour être très
pragmatique
le délai de 5 jours et est véritablement
très courts et le délai de huit jours
paraît plus opérant dans ces conditions
là le gouvernement n'est pas opposé à
cet amendement et propose un avis de
sagesse parce que le l'objet tel qu'il
est défini dans le document n'est pas
cohérent il évoque une période de douze
jours alors que en fait c'est 8 qui est
proposé merci monsieur masson monsieur
le président chers collègues je
considère que un délai de cinq jours
n'est absolument pas supportable car il
suffit qu'on ne soit pas là quand le
docu quand le dossier arrive on est
absent deux jours et puis finalement on
n'a pas le temps on n'a pas le temps de
préparer ou de faire quoi que ce soit il
faut savoir qu'il ya quand même des
décisions importantes et d'édition
sérieuses qui sont prises cinq jours
c'est tout à fait inadmissible surtout
lorsqu'il ya un problème sire que
lorsqu'il a pas de problème et c'est le
4 90% des dossiers
c'est évident que cinq jours ça suffit
mais quand il ya des choses à creuser un
élément ou des renseignements obtenir et
ses cinq jours c'est pas possible il
suffit qu'on soit qu'on soit absent
un petit peu faim ou qu'on soit retenu
par d'autres activités
on n'a pas le temps de prendre dans les
délais une connaissance suffisante pour
préparer la réunion
donc moi je suis tout à fait partisan de
ceux de cet amendement qui est
extrêmement pertinents merci monsieur
favier et ensuite monsieur le rapporteur
oui nous sommes également favorable à
l'amendement je pense effectivement que
ce délai de 8 jours est vraiment un
délai d'un an minimum pour permettre aux
élus de prendre connaissance de bonnes
manières des dossiers de la commission
permanente il faut savoir aujourd'hui
des commissions permanentes je pense
dans les conseils généraux ont une
délégation souvent très large avec et
traitent de sujets extrêmement diverse
et est compliquée un délai de cinq jours
effectivement ça serait bafouée
effectivement les les conditions de
travail des élus donc il faut savoir que
pour les séances du conseil les séances
plénières je crois que des aides
toujours donc huit jours pour les
commissions permanentes ça me paraît
raisonnable
merci madame goulet oui justement
monsieur le président la met unis je
pense que les délais seront d'autant
plus important que nous en aurons fini
avec le cumul des mandats et que l'on
les gens qui seront dans des
départements dans les régions auront
largement le temps de d'étudier leurs
dossiers mer c'est monsieur le
rapporteur
oui ce président aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de délai fixé de la commission a
proposé cinq jours ceci dit compte tenu
des des échanges qui viennent des
praticiens j'allais dire des des
collectivités territoriales je crois
qu'on peut s'en remettre à la sagesse de
l'assemblée
merci monsieur le rapporteur je vais
donc consulter la sagesse de l'assemblée
quels sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
de cet amendement avis contraire il est
adopté je mets aux voix l'article 12
quels sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
de l'article 12 avis contraire il est
adopté nous en arrivons à l'article 13
avec deux amendements en discussion
commune l'amendement 43 de monsieur kalt
en bacs
qu'ils défendent monsieur michel non je
suis arrivé monsieur kalt and back
pardon l'objet de cet amendement est de
maintenir à six mois le délai laissé aux
conseils municipaux pour l'adoption d'un
nouveau règlement intérieur
suite un renouvellement général en effet
ce délai est nécessaire pour procéder à
la consultation de l'ensemble des élus
de l'assemblée délibérante
et pour parvenir à l'élaboration du
règlement intérieur
les conseillers généraux et les
conseillers régionaux peu disposent de
plus de moyens que les simples
conseillers municipaux pour élaborer
leur nouveau règlement au suis aussi s'y
est tout à fait positif que ce délai
soit de 3 mois pour les conseils
généraux et des conseils régionaux
je crois qu on imposerait une contrainte
supplémentaire aux communes en mettant
un délai de trois mois au lieu des six
mois dont il dispose actuellement
je propose de faire une exception pour
les communes de plus de 100000 habitants
mais de maintenir ce délai de trois mois
pour les communes dans la population est
inférieure à cent mille habitants
le principe vous l'avez compris il
convient bien de distinguer les
assemblées régionales et départementales
des conseillers des conseils municipaux
pour ne pas créer une contrainte
supplémentaire dans les communes je vous
remercie
merci sous-amendement 75 monsieur masson
monsieur le président chers collègues
cet amendement est spécifique aux trois
départements d'alsace moselle en effet
dont on est dans ce domaine là on
présence d'un certain archaïsme hérité
d'eux
la période où ou disons l'alsace et la
moselle était annexée à l'allemagne
avant 1914 et bien actuellement il ya
une disposition qui subsistent qui a
pour conséquence que toutes les communes
sont obligées d'avoir un règlement
intérieur donc une commune de vingt
habitants de 10 habitants est obligé
d'avoir un règlement intérieur
alors je vous le dis tout de suite 95%
des communes de moins de 3500 habitants
n'appliquent pas ces dispositions qui
est complètement archaïque
simplement quand dans une commune il ya
quelqu'un qui veut embêter la
municipalité etc
il va au tribunal administratif et
disons on n'engage que tu bien les
registres hâtif est bien obligé
d'appliquer la loi et on engage disons
une procédure qui n'ont qui n'est a pu
en finir et donc l'objet de se
présentent un rendement c'est de faire
en sorte que en alsace moselle comme
dans les autres départements français et
bien l'obligation d'avoir un règlement
intérieur s'applique à partir de 3500
habitants et non pas à partir de zéro
habitants presque à la limite il ya des
très petites communes dans mon
département il ya des très petites
communes des communes qui n'ont même pas
de mairie allez leur demander il ya où
il ya et à douze ou treize habitants
allez leur demander d'établir un
règlement intérieur c'est complètement
surréaliste
merci je vais demander l'avis de la
commission sur l'amendement le
sous-amendement la commission a examiné
l'amendement mais n'a pas examiné le
le sous-amendement sur l'amendement de
monsieur kalt une bague c'est à dire le
numéro 43 elle a donné un avis favorable
sur le sous-amendement il n'a pas été
examinée je serais tenté de m'en
remettre à la sagesse de la de
l'assemblée du sénat
compte tenu de ce que je viens de dire
d'entendre de la part de monsieur masson
je dois dire que je partage assez ce qui
vient de dire merci à vis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président nous avons
bien entendu l'ensemble des arguments
qui ont été développés est effectivement
compte tenu de la réalité du terral
lorsque dans les communes et les petites
communes il s'agit d'organiser de mettre
sur le papier un règlement intérieur
pour laisser à chacun le temps de la
réflexion le ce délai ne nous paraît pas
incompatible donc le gouvernement donne
un avis de sagesse merci je vais donc
mettre aux voix d'abord le
sous-amendement 75 qui a reçu l'avis de
sagesse et de la commission et du
gouvernement quels sont ceux qui sont
pour son adoption
avis contraire il est adopté même vote
pour le 43 même vote
nous en arrivons à l'article 13 que je
vais mettre donc aux voix quels sont
ceux qui sont pour l'adoption d'articles
13 avis contraire il n'y en a pas il est
adopté
nous en arrivons donc à l'article 14 et
à l'amendement 33 qui le présente madame
meunier
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres cet article introduit dans la
loi des règles de quorum applicables aux
réunions de la commission compétente en
matière d'ouverture des plis que ton de
contenant les offres des prestataires
qui répondent en vue d'une délégation de
service public
il précise que cette commission délibère
valablement dès lors que plus de la
moitié de ses membres sont présents
c'est à dire à la majorité absolue il
prévoit en outre que si ce quorum n'est
pas atteint
la commission est convoqué une seconde
fois et délibère alors valablement quel
que soit le nombre de présents votre
rapporteur souligne que l'auteur de la
proposition de loi
entend ainsi permettre aux plus petites
communes qui peine parfois à réunir un
nombre suffisant d'élus de délibérer
valablement et s'il est exact que le
nombre de membres de cette commission
dans les petites communes pèse
proportionnellement plus au regard du
nombre de conseillers municipaux
elle n'en doivent elles n'en doivent pas
moins délibéré dans des conditions
garantissant toute transparence en effet
cette commission dresse ensuite la liste
des entreprises admises à présenter une
offre
et analyse leurs propositions nous
proposons donc par cet amendement de
maintenir
l'introduction dans la loi de la règle
du quorum fixé à la majorité absolue des
membres de cette commission
cette précision évitera d'éventuels
contentieux par contre nous proposons de
supprimer ce qui est cohérent la
possibilité de délibérer valablement
lors d'une seconde réunion sans que le
quorum soit atteint
c'est à dire quel que soit le nombre de
présents un tel assouplissement est bien
peu respectueux de la démocratie locale
par ailleurs ce sujet justifie d'être
traités dans une plus grande
transparence et les élus doivent faire
preuve de la disponibilité qu'implique
leur responsabilité d'élu d'ailleurs
pourquoi un texte portant revalorisation
du statut de l'élu est en chantier nous
en avons parlé tout à l'heure
merci merci ma chère collègue avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur où il
s'agit d'un amendement qui supprime la
possibilité pour les commissions
compétentes en matière délégation de
service public
lorsque le quorum n'a pas été atteint à
la première réunion de se réunir
valablement sans condition de quorum
après une nouvelle convocation
c'est donc l'idée donc que ces
commissions ne puisse délibérer que
lorsqu'un nombre minimum de membres est
présent la la la commission des lois
après examen et discussions a donné un
avis favorable à cet amendement
merci à vis du gouvernement madame la
ministre a priori j'aurais donné un avis
à priori à petit aurait aussi un avis
plutôt défavorable dans la mesure où
d'abord cette disposition existe pour
d'autres d'autres décisions importantes
à prendre et imaginer qu'à la deuxième
six ans un troisième vous n'ayez pas le
quorum je vous remettez en plus en
question pareille des marchés publics et
des lay afférents etc
honnêtement moi je préférerais qu'on
renonce à cette ouverture entre
guillemets là qui moi me semble posé
beaucoup plus de problèmes y compris par
rapport au code des marchés publics que
quand on va en résoudre et vous parlez
de contentieux ouverts et à la suite de
la deuxième réunion
je vous parlerai et on pourrait parler
longuement des cantons s'est ouvert si
la réunion ne se tient pas donc je pense
que face à cette double ouverture au
droit le gouvernement maintient un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur richard dent tout en
comprenant les motivations tout à fait
estimable de l'amendement proposé par ma
collègue car si un avis favorable de la
commission
je crois qu'il ya quand même des
arguments solides dans l'autre sens
puisque nous savons comment sont
composés les commissions d'appel
d'offres la minorité y représenter
d'autre part la grande majorité de ces
commissions se tiennent aux heures de
bureau
puisque elles ne peuvent soutenir
naturellement qu'avec l'assistance
administrative et technique des agents
de la collectivité qu'on ne fait pas
habituellement venir à des réunions
deux commissions nocturne et d'un
ministre a tout à fait raison de
rappeler que le dispositif de mise en
concurrence en vue d'une délégation est
encadrée dans des délais donc il ya à la
fois des considérations pratiques
c'est à dire la difficulté d'obtenir la
présence d des membres de la commission
à certains horaires quand ce sont des
salariés tout simplement ou des agents
qui ont leur activité professionnelle
ailleurs et d'autre part il ya le risque
s'il y a partage de la municipalité sur
le choix d'une délégation de donner à
deux membres de la commission d'appel
d'offres la possibilité de bloquer le
dispositif simplement ne venant pas sa
part est démocratiquement discutable
donc il me semble que seul le dispositif
traditionnel qui est d'exiger un quorum
pour une assemblées délibératives
quelconque même consultatif d'ailleurs à
la première réunion est de dispenser du
quorum à la deuxième répondent mieux aux
nécessités à mon avis de la bonne
gestion de la concurrence
merci mon cher collègue je vais donc
mettre aux voix à l'amendement 33
monsieur d'olivier joue dans prix oui
merci monsieur présent je rappelle que
effectivement pour revenir à ce que
vient de dire monsieur richard que
j'approuve totalement mais que
l'objectif de l'article 14
c'était déjà de faire un progrès par
rapport à ce qui existait précédemment
puisque dans cette commission
il n'y avait pas de règles de quorum
donc effectivement la ligne sur les
autres commissions qui existe sur des
sujets quand même assez proches qu'ils
soient les marchés où que ce soit ce
type de commission localité c'est pour
avoir une harmonisation
mais si on met des règles de quorum
importante à la deuxième réunion on n'en
sortira jamais et on va arriver à des
blocages qui vont est insupportable
alors quand on connaît la durée de
validité des offres et cetera et cetera
on peut se trouver dans des systèmes où
vous avez des hommes vous ne pouvez pas
les étudier et puis le jour où vous
arrivez à réunir votre commission
l'offre n'est plus valable
donc on est dans des blocages merci marc
meunier
tout ce qui vient des tournis
l'amendement est retiré merci
l'amendement ait retiré je vais donc
mettre aux voix l'article 14 quels sont
ceux qui sont pour son adoption invite
contraire il est adopté même vote pour
le 15 mai mme vote pour le 16 pour le 17
j'en arrive donc à l'article 18 avec
trois amendements en discussion commune
nous commençons par le 46 madame meunier
mesdames les ministres
initialement l'article 18 de la
proposition de loi présentée par le
sénateur doligé entendait supprimer
l'obligation pour les communes de
disposer d'un ccas ou de les autoriser à
le dissoudre dans un contexte
d'aggravation de la précarité la
progression des besoins sociaux cette
proposition est à mon sens mal venu
plusieurs mois plus tard donc nous voilà
pour discuter d'une faculté enfin rendre
facultatif la création d'un ccas ça
m'apparaît est une fausse bonne idée ça
fragilise davantage d'action sociale de
proximité est simple il simplifie en
rien le travail des élus qu'ils ont à
faire face à une demande sociale en
constante progression l'actualité est
elle à ce cruel est bien réelle
l'absence de ces c est sur une commune
ne règle pas les problèmes sociaux
auxquels elle doit faire face qu'elle
ait 3 1000 2000 ou 1000 habitants une
commune est confrontée aux mêmes
problèmes et aux mêmes besoins en la
matière et si une commune n'a pas les
moyens de le faire via un ccas
il n'y a pas de raison non plus qu'elle
ait plus de moyens pour gérer en direct
la mise en oeuvre des politiques
sociales et dans ce contexte il n'est
pas question de précariser encore
davantage les populations rurales en
rendant optionnels action sociale à
l'endroit où la vivent les gens et ce
n'est pas parce que l'on vit dans une
petite commune que l'on doit être touché
par la fatalité et vivre moins bien
qu'ailleurs avec moins de protection et
moins de droits
le ccs je le rappelle est un outil de
proximité qui informent orientent
conseil au quotidien
les familles les personnes isolées les
personnes en difficulté les personnes
âgées
bref toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont
besoin de soutien de la part des
pouvoirs publics pour cuivres mieux pour
rebondir ou pour s'en sortir
dès lors je vous propose par cet
amendement de muscler le dispositif
actuel en renforçant la présence de cet
outil
sur l'ensemble des territoires de notre
pays le développement de
l'intercommunalité social permet dans ce
cadre de donner la possibilité aux
petites communes qui n'ont pas tcs de
mutualiser leurs moyens humains et
matériels pour mieux répondre à la
demande sociale sur leur territoire il
s'agit de rendre obligatoire la création
par le pci 200 trains comme un coeur
intercommunal d'action sociale dans les
territoires intercommunaux ou les
communes ne disposent pas d'assez crs
le crs disposera de compétences égales
sur l'ensemble du territoire garantie
d'une offre sociale a minima les ccs
existant auparavant pourront bien
entendu conserver et développer une
offre d'intervention le cis rend
possible notamment la création de
services d'équipements lourds
structurants dans le domaine de la
petite enfance mais aussi des personnes
âgées ou de l'insertion
voilà mes chers collègues je vous
propose de passer à une logique de moins
disant social à la création partout et
pour tous
d'outils utiles performant et juste
merci madame avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
l'amendement numéro 8 de monsieur masson
oui les propos de notre collègue partent
d'un postulat qui est que si il y à un
ccas les gens démunis démunis n'ont plus
de problème tout est réglé alors je
crois qu'il faut il faut quand même il
faut quand même être réaliste et le un
crs n'apporte strictement rien ce qui
apporte est ce que la commune mais ce
qui apporte est ce que la commune mais
comme argent pour aider pour aider les
personnes qui ont des problèmes si la
commune ne met pas d'argent
ben le ccas ne règle rien et le bon bon
bon permettait permettez que je
m'exprime je vous hais si vous voulez
intervenir si vous voulez laisser
monsieur masson à s'exprimer s'il vous
plaît quand même par les bons à voici
alors je crois que il est complètement
aberrant de vouloir prétendre que par
exemple dans une commune de 100
habitants
il faut absolument créer un crs car
comme ça il y aura plus de difficultés
il paraîtrait d'après ce que l'on veut
nous faire croire
c'est que si dans une commune de 100
habitants et bahia celle ci reste tout
est réglé tout ira mieux il y aura plus
démunis il y aura plus de rmistes sur
happy du rsa et bien moi je le dis c'est
une aberration complète et c'est de la
technocratie complète de vouloir imposer
à des communes de 20 30 ou 100 habitants
l'obligation d'avoir un crs alors je le
dis d'autant plus que créer un crs
c'est-à-dire un centre communal d'action
sociale suppose qu'on y met des moyens
et du personnel donc le peu d'argent que
la commune de vingt habitants mettra
éventuellement pour l'aide sociale
le peu d'argent ira à financer le
fonctionnement du ccas
alors je pense qu'à un moment donné il
faut un minimum de bon sens moi dans les
grandes villes je suis tout à fait
d'accord
un ccas permet d'avoir une gestion de
proximité et cetera
mais il me semble tout à fait aberrant
de vouloir obliger des communes
moins de 3000 à 3500 d'habitants et en
particulier les toutes petites communes
en milieu rural dont parfois la commune
sur dix ans ne reçoit jamais aucune
demande de qui que ce soit parce que
quand vous avez un habitant dans la
commune
on savait pas de demande on va quand
même pas obligé cette commune à payer
des frais de fonctionnement d'un
établissement public ccas simplement
pour faire plaisir aux corporatismes de
l'unca ce parce qu'il faut bien voir et
je tiens à le dire ici que l'une casse
donc l'union nationale des ccas a fait
un lobbying forcené pour dire il faut
absolument qu'il est nécessaire et ce
partout sinon c'est la fin du monde
et bien moi je le dis dans mon
département il ya beaucoup de petites
communes compact crs et c'est pas du
tout la fin du monde et les habitants de
ces petites communes en milieu rural qui
n'ont pas de crs sont pas plus
malheureux a que ceux de communes
particules en grande cure des crs
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
moi je crois que autant bon pour des
grandes communes bien kg et des six mois
je veux bien mais je crois qu'il ya un
seuil de 3500 qui sert un petit peu tout
le temps d'ailleurs tout à l'heure pour
le règlement intérieur des conseils
municipaux
c'était le seuil de 3500 moi je suis
partisan du seuil de 3500 et c'est pour
ça que j'ai déposé cet amendement
merci monsieur masson amendement 71
monsieur le rapporteur et vous donnerez
par la même occasion l'avis de la
commission sur les deux précédents
amendements oui c'est un amendement un
petit peu différent qui propose de
supprimer la halle à 19h parle de
l'amendement sa sortie roussin il a un
petit peu différent des deux précédents
il propose de supprimer la les à
l'alinéa pardo 19 à la suite de
l'adoption de l'ordonance du 31 mai 2012
qui apportait extension adaptation du
code de l'action sociale et des familles
au département de mayotte donc je peux
dire que c'est un amendement de
coordination qui pose pas débat sur le
fond je donne peut-être la vie sur les
deux os oui monsieur le rapporteur laure
sur sur les deux autres élabore sur
l'amendement numéro 46 et un amendement
qui dispose que si toutes les communes
ne disposent pas julien d'un centre
d'action sociale le groupement de
communes procède à la création d'un
centre intercommunal d'action sociale
dass et yes c'est une idée intéressante
sauf qu'à centre intercommunal d'action
sociale ne peut être créé que si
l'incompétence d'action sociale relève
de l'intérêt communautaire et cet
intérêt communautaire il ne peut être
défini que par les communes membres de
le pci
il faut donc le pci soit conformément au
principe de spécialité de ses
compétences compétent en matière
d'action sociale pour qu'ils soient
habilitées à chréa seyes d'oc au niveau
de cet amendement je ne peux compte tenu
de ces règles qui s'imposent émettre un
avis défavorable sur l'amendement
numéro vite c'est un moment qui propose
un seuil de 3500 habitants en deçà
duquel la création d'un c 'est ce serait
serait facultative alors que la loi
propose 15 cents habitants la commission
qui a un avenir le seuil de 15 cents
habitants plutôt que 3500 habitants donc
c'est un avis défavorable également sur
le monde on dit merci à vis du
gouvernement sur ces trois amendements
mal merci monsieur le président sur
l'amendement de la commission donc qui
était essentiellement de cohérence et
aucun problème pour nous sur
l'amendement présenté par monsieur
masson nous tenons à ne pas avoir des
dérogations par rapport au niveau qui
était celui déjà en vigueur
je ne reviens pas sur ces arguments qui
lui a qui lui appartiennent sur la sur
l'amendement de présenté par madame
meunier sur l'amendement numéro 46 il ya
plusieurs aspects au sujet que vous
traitez et lors de la conférence sur la
pauvreté l'exclusion
nous avons été amenés avec des
responsables du rapport sur la
gouvernance de de ce qu'on appelle la
lutte contre les exclusions avec michel
der elle rapporte thierry justement à se
poser la question du rôle des ccs pour
l'application d'un certain nombre de
mesures est une application avec
discernement aussi d'un certain nombre
de mesures il ya deux choses donc
disais-je
il ya d'une part le fait que les ccs
agissent par délégation du département
donc il faudrait que le chef du file qui
sera je crois je pense j'espère même
confirmé dans le cadre de nouveaux
textes sur la décentralisation puisse
avoir en face de lui un 1 6 et 7h
communal pourquoi pas à l'heure où je
vous parle je suis pas totalement fermé
à cette idée
sauf qu'aujourd'hui pour ce qui relève
seulement du ccs est à dire à la fois la
prévention est la prévention les aides
sociales à la personne souvent le ccs
est un lieu intéressant c'est un lieu
dans lequel les élus
les associations concernées sont amenés
à discuter en toute discrétion et dans
dans un lieu clos auquel on fait
totalement confiance de la situation
d'une personne d'une famille qui ne
relèvent pas de dispositif du
département qui ne relèvent pas de
dispositif généraux mais qui peuvent
avoir besoin d'une aide particulière moi
je trouve que ce lieu de discussion et
un lieu intéressant
le problème que que vous posez et c'est
effectivement un s'il n'y a pas si
aucune d'ailleurs commune de 1500
habitants ça pourrait être le cas
comment créer un comité intercommunal
alors l'argument du rapporteur et de
qualité d'abord on ne peut pas créer une
commission spéciale et intercommunales
s'il n'y a pas la compétence
si la parité n'a pas la compétence donc
moi je réfléchis à d'autres solutions à
l'heure où je vous parle parce que je
trouve que vous avez raison de poser
cette question
on a des intercommunalités qui ont
trente quarante communes de petite
taille qui pourrait au moins par bloc
avoir besoin de ce rassemblement
il faut qu'on réfléchisse à peut-être
des associations de social je ne sait à
l'heure où je vous parle
mais en tout cas l'intercommunalité ne
peut avoir ne peut créer ce comité
ce centre social intercommunal que se
sentent pardon d'action avec que sina la
compétence willy a à la fois une bonne
idée et une impossibilité en termes de
compétences des collectivités
territoriales donc moi je serais plutôt
favorable à ce que vous retiriez votre
amendement qu'on propose pour les ccas
communaux dans les zones dont vous
parlez de réfléchir à la façon de
travailler ensemble mais en tout cas
cette disposition n'est pas acceptable
en droit et nous compliquerait la tâche
et enfin vous pourriez dans votre
hypothèse avoir des communes qui
tiennent à garder leur ccs d'autres qui
disent puisqu'il ya centre intercommunal
je ferme le bien vous pourriez même
avoir des doublons donc toutes ces
réserves étant dit je je m'engage avec
anne marie escoffier à regarder cette
question et donc du coup je vous demande
le retrait
merci madame la ministre à leurs
explications de vote madame boulet oui
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres moi je les soutenir
l'amendement 46 mais le gouvernement
viennent demander son retrait ce que je
voulais dire c'est que moi je travaille
beaucoup avec le ccas d'argentan dans
mon département et que quel que soit le
nombre de dispositifs vous avez toujours
des gens qui passent entre les mailles
du filet voilà et je pense que cette
grande conférence sur l'exclusion est là
et la pauvreté va être encore une
occasion de mettre en exergue les
failles de dispositifs même s'ils sont
nombreux même si les bénévoles sont
nombreux même si les bonnes intentions
sont nombreux il ya quand même des
personnes qui restent totalement en
dehors de ces circuits de réinsertion
d'où l'émotion très importante que la
proposition de loi de lits g sursee ccas
a fait naître de la part des gens qui
passent énormément de temps à lutter au
jour le jour au cas par cas avec avec
ces gens qui sont évidemment des exclus
et qui sont dans des situations
difficiles donc si l'amendement 46 et
retiré ben je ne soutiendrai pas et s'il
est maintenu je le soutiendrai à percy
monsieur favier oui nous sommes déjà
exprimé sur ce sujet dans les débats
précédents mais je voudrais insister
nous sommes effectivement défavorable à
cet article 18 qui seront facultatifs
l'existence des crs y compris pour les
communes de moins de 15 cents habitants
il s'agit là effectivement d'un
véritable recul du service public dans
sur les territoires on vient de parler
de la conférence sur la pauvreté
on sait que cette pauvreté touche y
compris évidemment des toutes petites
communes et que le traitement justement
de ces questions de la provôté doivent
se faire aussi dans la proximité
c'est la raison pour laquelle je ne suis
pas aussi favorable à l'amendement qui a
été proposée d'un ccas intercommunale
parce que bien évidemment on a parfois
des intercommunalités de très grande
taille donc avec si demain
on aboutit c'est simplement un seul ces
crs à l'échelle de l'intercommunalité
on aboutirait évidemment un éloignement
très grand très important entre la
population et le et la structure
susceptible de donc de prendre en compte
leurs problèmes et donc je pense que
cette ces questions doivent pouvoir
rester dans la proximité puis on sait
que des communes évidemment profiterait
de l'occasion pour des mesures
d'économies de l'existence d'un à ces
séances intercommunal pour évidemment
supprimé lors leur ccas communal
donc pour toutes ces raisons je ne suis
pas effectivement favorable à cet
amendement et encore moins évidemment
pour celui qui rend facultatif à une
échelle encore plus élevé puisque notre
collègue parle de moins 3500 habitants
mais pourquoi pas 5000 10000 etc
on voit bien que quand on est dans cette
logique là un moment donné eh bien on va
vers une seule logique est la réduction
une fois de plus de l'aide et de
l'action nécessaire que nous devons
porter à l'attention de nos concitoyens
les plus fragilisés
merci monsieur richard je voulais à mon
tour exprimé une réserve sur l'idée qui
figure aujourd'hui dans le texte a été
approuvé par la commission de rendre
facultatif le ccas en dessous de 1500
habitants
non pas que je m'oppose cette idée mais
il me semble qu'il y à il ya une deux
précautions à prendre
la première c'est de se dire ministre en
a parlait à l'instant s'il n'ya pas le
ccas la solution cohérente c'est qu'il
ya un cis est donc
s'il n'y a plus d'obligation juridique
en dessous de 15 cents militants les
communes ne sont pas spécialement poussé
à chercher l'accord à la majorité
qualifiée normal pour créer un cis en
conférant conférant à la communauté là
où vraiment y'a pas les ressources
humaines pour faire du social dans la
commune de passer à une échelle
intercommunale
donc ça c'est un premier inconvénient de
la suppression de l'obligation
le deuxième est là j'ai des excuses à
faire aux collègues de la commission
parce que j'avais jamais indiqué lors du
débat sur ce sujet là que j'essaierai de
faire une proposition
c'est qu'une fois qu'on l'a dit il ya
plus de ccas il faut quand même bien
traités et dossiers et donc il existe
dans le grand 2 du nouveau 123,4 proposé
dans le texte la possibilité pour la
commune d'exercer directement les
compétences du ccas sauf qu'il ya des
règles de procédure il s'agit à ce
moment-là de délivrer des aides
individualisées d'examiner des dossiers
et qui comporte de forts éléments de
cockpits de confidentialité donc ce qui
m'ennuie c'est qu'on met dans la loi
telle qu'elle
l'idée la commune va exercer les
missions du crs sans préciser avec quels
conditions et dans quel cadre légal
merci monsieur van beirendonck
bon sens de l'intervention de madame la
ministre c'est à dire qui militent pour
qu'on examine un fond cette question là
dans le cadre de la réforme territoriale
première réflexion c'est le chef de file
à au département un mois pas suspect je
suis un mec le président du conseil
général du nord et il est le président
de l'unps casse bon quand j'ai dit ça et
si je suis le raisonnement je devrai
trouver dans l'office des hlm que gère
le département du nord le premier acteur
de paix l haÿ du département du nord est
ce le cas madame demandé les chiffres
donc je pense qu'il faut aussi
s'articuler avec la compétence
intercommunale et la délégation des
aides à la pierre et ça milite pour que
la question du de l'intercommunalité de
la compétence en matière de ccas soit
vraiment poser calmement sereinement
sans en faire un modèle
qu'ils soient et
pas adaptable à la proximité tant qu'on
y est et et je termine par là on a
beaucoup parlé ces derniers jours
c'est quand même dommage le rsa activité
mais tous les bénéficiaires n'ont pas
intérêt juin interrogez-vous aussi sur
le terrain comment ça se passe
le département qui donne une convention
qui paye quelques références dès qu'il
est devant un gros ccas pour que il gère
une certaine forme d'accueil améliorées
s'agit touche pas à les voir la caf et
on jour quatre coins avec les pauvres
dans les grandes villes
on a certes un grand chef de file le
département on aura ccas on à la caf et
basques eux attendre tout le monde sait
qu'on mette un peu de rationalité
peut-être aussi un peu de solidarité
intercommunale
parce que vous conviendrez que les
communes comme dit l'un comme moi qui
sommes confrontés à à ces questions là
c'est pas bien sûr qu'on va parler plat
équation mais on attend aussi que les
outils de l'action sociale se
définissent à l'échelle intercommunale
si monsieur doligé oui merci monsieur le
président mon coach avait introduit cet
article 18 je pensais pas que ça ferait
autant de remous et pourquoi on a mis
cet article 18 parce que je sais pas si
chacun 2,5 milliards déjà 36000 communes
en france qu'elle existe et qu'on en
crée plus et que les crs sont
obligatoires dans les 36000 communes
aujourd'hui donc théoriquement il y en a
dans les 36000 communes
bon allez voir ce qui est la réalité la
réalité ce qui a pas un tiers des
communes de france qui a des crs ce qui
veut dire que vous avez des deux tiers
des communes de france qui sont dans
l'illégalité
normalement la loi s'applique à tout le
monde et ainsi les autorités publiques
faisait appliquer la loi il devrait elle
devrait obliger toutes les communes à
avoir des ccs comme cela a été dit tout
à l'heure
chacun comprend que dans les communes de
100 150 300 habitants on puisse pas
parfois créer des crs et que la commune
traite directement elle connaît ses
habitants elle traite directement ces
problèmes je rappellerai aussi frais
regarder la règle de traitement des cfa
de création des crs vous devez faire un
budget donc quand vous n'avez un ccas
avec 100 habitants moi j'ai des mères
qui m'ont écrit j'ai obligé de faire un
budget on me demande mon budget j'ai pas
d'argent dans le ccs parce que giresse
ne fonctionne pas je dois payer des
charges sociales parce que je crois
qu'il ya une personne qui doit y être en
partie affectés même s'ils ces crs ne
fonctionne pas enfin bref on tombe sur
la tête
l'objectif de ce texte quand même la
simplification et d'essayer de faire en
sorte que toutes les communes qui n'ont
pas créé le ccas aujourd'hui elles sont
libres de le faire
voilà pour l'examen de la proposition de
loi d'eric doligé sur la simplification
des normes applicables aux collectivités
territoriales vous pourrez la revoir à
tout instant sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne fin
d'après-midi à vous sur public sénat